exhale hands to heart center and you got
two more times on both sides are we
doing the whole three so I was gonna say
yeah yeah I can do it but just because I
can do it you scoured the city for the
hottest food fitness disciplines these
are the workouts everyone's talking
about
we've got turf set white-eye tabata yoga
and boot camp it's your body
this is fighting I'm Amanda and I live
yoga this is your at-home yoga upper
body workout all right guys so we're
here with a upper-body workout yoga
specific okay what are we going to be
doing today so I'll show you we're gonna
start it down facing dog we're gonna
ship or it into a plank positions we're
gonna shift everything over into the
outside of our right foot right hand
stability you take that top leg off
holding it here hold for three breaths
come back to Center
step foot to thumb come all the way up
into a high lunge and interlace our
hands behind our back rolling the
shoulders back lifting the chest up and
start to fold forward it's the arms
towards the front of the room on your
inhale you lift all the way back up to
your high lunge open out to your warrior
two can you flip that palm reverse
you're getting a nice stretch here
straighten that top leg reach back free
bend the knee hands go down to the mat
step back to a plank pose lower halfway
chaturanga upward facing dog to try to
shoulders chest exhale back downward
facing dog
it's up the knees look to the front of
your mat jump there step he turns up
hands to heart center shift forward into
plank and then coming to the outside of
your right foot right hand oh this is
gonna be fun yep side plank now I want
you to keep lifting yeah lift those hips
up that's it
top leg off hold it here inhale exhale
one
inhale come back to your plank pose
bring your right knee into your chest as
you step foot to thumb
come all the way to a high lunge so
reach arms up yeah now interlace the
hands behind your low back roll the
shoulders back
now fold towards your right thigh there
you go deep breath in deep breath out
two more there reach all the way up find
your high lunge and then open out to
your warrior two
now you flip your palm reverse your
warrior now straighten out your front
leg soon reverse that's right
feel that stretch they are the right
side body yeah there you go come back to
your warrior two revenge your right knee
and bring your hands down to the mat
step back to plank pose lower halfway
chaturanga upward facing dog downward
facing dog let's do this on our left
side you ready oh yes soften knees look
to the top of your mat jumper step and
then reach arms up to the sky exhale
hands to heart center and you got two
more times on both sides okay to recap
you start in downward facing dog
position plank pose rotate right side
plank interlace your hands behind your
back fold forward
stretch your shoulders back hands up
back to your lunge position open to
warrior two alright reach back and
stretch then you're gonna take your
front leg straighten it out to triangle
pose ever see your child worsen your
triangle then you're gonna go to plank
position
yeah lower halfway to chaturanga upward
facing dog downward facing dog and then
you breathe soften your knees jump to
the front of your mat hands to heart
center and you start all over again with
the other side of the body three times
booyakasha that was tough to remember
all that good job make sure to subscribe
so you don't miss out on any other
fighting weight episodes